hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cyber
we're gonna be checking out the video
today that I am very excited to watch
dying light parkour
P o V live-action trailer oh hey hey
just remembered this guy that cyber
channel over here that's me
he has a gameplay videos of dying light
actually yeah I just saw I was literally
just watching one it was pretty funny
you should check it out I make jokes he
makes jokes yeah and then my buddy and I
slap each other with wrenches yeah then
they slap each other with her dicks it's
[ __ ] awesome god damn it he didn't
have Santa said I forgot I was on the
real Regis that's what happens when you
come here ah come here oh my god it's
the weirdest music choice
you
oh yes we help kid
[ __ ] dude zero is awesome
where is this
ah so scary
she's me like so terrified of what this
guys doing
it's July I've never seen a POV parkour
video do they're intense
nice
whoa
holy [ __ ]
oh my god
how are they still following him oh my
god this must be a really scary it's
kind of terrifying
Oh
Jesus cute though right there you'd be
dead this would be such a cool movie my
god
it's crazy the zombies do parkour to
kick him in the face that's too bad that
sucks
is really sad watch this guy in this
whole adventure try to escape
he just gets killed in the end it was
really depressing dude
all of that parkour he should have been
like my mom by now at one point I wish
she said like am I not doing enough I am
hopping across every building right now
good she's you know the parkour was
insane and that was really cool seeing
from this survivor point of view and
looking all those zombies I was pretty
scary through some jump scares cottage
looking you tense dude they should
totally do a movie where that features
that kind of shot at some points like a
sequence where it's like in a movie
where it's POV it's parkour and zombies
yeah I'll be really [ __ ] sweet be a
good look surprise this isn't like a
Kickstarter for an actual film but next
we'll fill yeah good it could be hood
dude earrings the editing is great the
parkour is awesome and then the zombie
stuff whenever you do see them it is
scary also consider like they had to
[ __ ] sound design all every single
yeah grab and like landing and all that
stuff because it was it probably just a
GoPro so all you heard was how Wiggly
wagon oh yeah great sound fit yeah
that's real pro just kind of which sound
doesn't get enough praise no it doesn't
know cuz that's very impressive yeah cuz
what an impressive [ __ ] video that is
a great [ __ ] video [ __ ] and unlike
just a small note after playing the game
and watching this like the way bet he
had his hand start up because obviously
you probably went when you're parkouring
problem would have is yeah like as
exaggerated I don't know if that's just
a result of him doing parkour but it
certainly looked exactly like the game
oh yeah totally yeah like that was the
other impressed thing because there's a
wait I have seen a parkour video it
way.this there's this movie that they're
getting that's on Kickstarter called toy
forgot has this guy named sharlto copley
at copeley it's from first-person point
of view with a GoPro and it's an action
film too and it looks great hey they
could do something very similar is gonna
become a new genre [ __ ] feel it yeah
like it's gonna become like the next
like [ __ ] found-footage kind of thing
but it's good but it's gonna be parkour
like action movies horror movies like
because it could work Anakin and it's
very effective like the lighting was all
great throughout that whole video every
moment of it is just it's solid do you
say well we're filming this is weird I
don't know what happened this room
that's so rude coffee with my system I
love that video it's awesome I genuinely
do anyway guys thanks for mentioning
that video is out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and you can go to Dan's gaming
channel to check out those dynamite
videos and then maybe you want to
subscribe afterwards based off his
content and how good it is and how shiny
my button look at how shiny the button
looks and hey we're not just on YouTube
we're also on Instagram and Twitter what
you're kidding me right
I'm gonna send a tweet right now let's
tweet we're tweeting InDesign as a week
we send out a tweet that doesn't make
sense unless you've watched the video
yeah okay well hashtag dying light okay
hashtag dying light my tits were huge
then they were small but now they're
bigger than ever if you're here because
you heard about this tweet that's what
happens man boobs are better than ever
tweet tweet and shout outs what
continues to go to facebook.com slash
the real reject shout outs where you can
earn yourself a shout out by saying
something interesting like my tits were
huge now if once were big butt
then were small but now I'm bigger than
ever yes exactly thank you I love you
hashtag goodbye